[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the summer
of chess here in st. Louis we're all
very excited for the st. Louis rapid
enlist as the second one of its kind and
it should be a spectacular event it's a
third stop on the grand chest tour we've
already had two amazing events in Livan
and in Paris and so the players have had
a chance to rest a little bit at least
most of them and come to this event
prepared and ready to do battle well we
certainly have to thank Shannon Bailey
who was the chief curator of the world
chess Hall of Fame and her incredible
staff for hosting this event miss really
spectacular place thank you very much
Anna and we would have no such event -
the miracle that is American chess not
only here in st. Louis but the rippling
effect the title across the world of
chess if it weren't for the largesse the
generosity and persistent dedication of
Rex and dr. Jeanne sing feel so thank
you very much
[Applause]
nothing happens without visionaries and
unfortunately he could not be here today
but one garry kasparov should certainly
be thanked he's always been a visionary
we know he has left his imprint on the
world of chess forever
so Gary wherever you are we hope you're
watching thank you so much and there's a
team that works for the grand chest tour
along with everyone we're not here
Graham Jorgenson Mike Khodorkovsky and
also Malcolm Payne they're on the board
and they should be watching as well I
believe they will be coming at some
point soon we also want to thank the
sponsor is a grand chest tour of course
this is a collaboration and that
collaboration involves great cities
around the world first of all we did
have this event in Louisville and so we
like to thank young chilavert and your
next move for putting on just an amazing
event and one of the great locations in
the world of chess it's almost like a
castle and it's a special pleasure for
us to enjoy that so yawn thank you very
much for that and Zhu Ben Howser please
get my machine Ben Hauser from the
French team in Paris with Colliers
International certainly Vivendi and all
the support is there that studio their
studio is the ceiling is about five
times the size of this one just sitting
a spectacular location Rex I'm waiting
for you to build a studio like that for
us you're gonna do it yeah whatever I
say that's good that's the right answer
that's the right answer
well we've had we've had three two
events so far this is the third and it
just been amazing we will get to a
player introductions momentarily but
first we'll get a few words from the
executive director up this English chess
club
Tony rich
[Applause]
thank you all very much really happy to
be here with you today
I you know I always joke around I'm not
sure which is my favorite event you know
the rapid blitz and the Sinquefield Cup
the Junior Championships the US
Championship the US Women's Championship
we really have a unique opportunity here
in st. Louis to spotlight chests at all
of its levels but I have to say I think
the rapid ablates is probably one of my
favorite events not just do we see great
luminaries and and chest talent like
this but you know we're able to really
put on a great show we have great
commentators we have a really wonderful
event in store for everybody just some
logistical things so everybody knows
Alexander Chris Chuck's flight was a
little later than everybody else is so
that's why we only have nine of the 10
players up here at this point but yes he
will make it in time for round one
weather weather willing so let's keep
our fingers crossed that we see Alex
here too so the reason why we host these
events
apart from spotlighting these great
chess towns from around the world is
because of the benefits that chefs
really brings to to st. Louis to kids
especially we run programs at about a
hundred schools in the st. Louis area
and whenever you're able to see you know
your idol these great chefs heroes up
here in your own hometown and get an
autograph it really is something special
so thank you all for joining us we're
very excited to see you here and I'm
really looking forward to the chest
thanks
thank you Tony and we mentioned her
before and she gets a few words once
more and she can have the mic for as
long as she wants because that's the
kind of lady she is dr. Zee's Ginny
Ziegfeld thank you for all coming back
for those of you were here for the first
time and this is gonna be a very
exciting event it's so much fun to have
you guys it feels like you're like my
cousins or something my young cousins so
we really appreciate you're all coming
back and for those of you who cannot be
here my job is to introduce Rex okay
so I've said a few things over the years
so I'm trying to be nice right oh so
anyway Rex has been playing chesses way
before that I I met him and he doesn't
like to talk about when we played
together since it was not a good
experience I won one game come on so in
other words then and the other thing you
got to remember is that I let him play
chess because I said to him how
expensive could it be so anyway I like
to introduce you the Godfather of
American chess Rex Sinquefield
[Applause]
Thank You genie it's really nice when
she's on the spot cuz then she has to
say something nice about me so I want to
welcome all of you this is certainly my
and I think all of our favorite time of
the year when the world's best chess
players come to the best chess city in
the world sink Louis and I certainly
want to give a big round of applause and
welcome amazing commentary team
Yaser maurice and jennifer the best in
the world in any sport period and then
also the tremendous team that does all
the production work spectrum studios
randy Sinquefield kita
Tami everybody at silverback Rosa
Leonard and all of those and of course
joy first and foremost and Shannon
Bailey curator this wonderful
institution thank you all for everything
you do
[Applause]
the Chess Club and the world chess Hall
of Fame's you work so well together and
it's just an incredible job day in and
day out throughout the years you make
all of them come to life and it's truly
amazing thank you all of you for
everything you do in that regard now
today is the day I just learned this
recently today is the day that Missouri
was founded as a state in 1821 and
having been there at the time I know I
look young for my age
it was a wonderful day yesterday we
unveiled a banner on the side of a
building
at 18th and olive about three miles
straight east of here and that was the
site of the first official World
Championship match between Zurcher torte
and Steines the sights of that
championship match were New York st.
Louis and New Orleans and they left New
York with zuker torte very much in the
lead they left st. Louis with Steiners
having completely turned the match
around and he goes on to New Orleans and
wins and becomes one of the most
impressive world champions ever so now
we could of course get to celebrate
because st. Louis has its own resident
world champion contender grandmaster
Fabiano Caro Anna
[Applause]
and I'm fairly confident he's going to
bring the World Championship back to st.
Louis where it belongs now I have to
tell you quite honestly when I brought
the world championship here in 1886 what
what you got a problem with that
oh man so anyway Viviano all of us are
rooting for you and wishing you the best
of luck and you're becoming a great
world champion now it's important that
we have our public officials here mayor
Lyta cruson could not make it but the
man who runs the entire region the st.
Louis County much larger than the city
is Steve stinger he's the county
executive he's just coming off of a
recent election in which he was
re-elected in a very tight and exciting
race but I think a resounding victory
the people of st. Louis said they loved
his leadership and we were very grateful
for his presence here today County
Executive Steve stinger
[Applause]
thank you all very much it's great to be
here with you tonight and it is a
pleasure and an honor to speak once
again to some of the world's greatest
chess players in the world's greatest
chess fans so it's great to be here and
yes we did just come off of an election
it was not exactly a landslide but it
was a very nice victory of victory as a
victory but as sure as we're all aware
the st. Louis region is the chess
capital of the world period and I think
it bears repeating in light of the large
number of visitors who have attended
previous chess tournaments here it's
easy to see how the st. Louis area
benefits from its standing as the
epicentre of chess and we heard what
Tony said and he's absolutely correct
and we also have to talk about the
economic factor the st. Louis chess club
plays host to ten major tournaments
every year and one event alone the 2018
US Championships held at the Chess Club
in March generated an estimated 1
million dollars for our local economy
and I think it was even more than that
and then there's also the ripple effect
of being a destination for world-class
chess many of the game's top players now
live in the st. Louis region and since
I've been County Executive it seems like
that number is growing all the time it's
been about three and a half years and
this of course adds to our reputation of
having a skilled innovative and
intelligent population which in turn
makes the st. Louis region an attractive
place for businesses to recruit and hire
workers and again I appreciate the
opportunity to participate in tonight's
rapid and blitz ceremony and I spent my
I extend my special thanks to Rex and
Jeanne sig field for their sponsorship
of this tournament and for all they have
done for our hometown thank you very
much
thank you for that report so much
employee I always have to talk about
these guys right that's my job
to talk about these guys and it's and to
introduce them I I always want to think
of something new to say what's different
and we recognize that they're great
players but something that Steve said to
me really struck me about the greatest
players in the world it's it's not only
that they're the greatest players in the
world
I'd like to contextualize it this time
in my introduction I'm going to start
down here with the grandmasters directly
to my right he is the number three
player in the world and rapid chess
that's why he's here because he
obviously had to have some skills
otherwise he get killed but he's also
the greatest player from his country
since one josé raúl capablanca think
about that but the great world champion
of coupling of the third world champion
for him to be the greatest ever in that
great chess loving nation of Cuba please
give a warm welcome to grandmaster
linear dubbing guess
[Applause]
to his right he has won the Sinquefield
Cup and he did that last year and he's
clearly one of the best players in the
world but he also happens to be the
greatest player of all time from his
country and he is also a mathematician
he corrected me when I was at a ceremony
a couple of days ago and said I said 136
years ago was when this fine it's Zuko
sort of match happened but it was
actually 132 is that right max he makes
him very happy I think it makes an
unhappy that I got the number right but
nevertheless the greatest player ever in
the history of France Maxime by Sheila
Gras
[Applause]
this next player he has extreme
competition for the role of greatest
player born in his country extreme
competition there was one Garry Kasparov
who was born in his country but he has
followed up and I think we can safely
say he's the second greatest ever born
in his nation he happens to be the
number three player on the planet coming
off a resounding victory in Beal we look
forward to his great form here chakra
all my material for myself I'm I'm gonna
give the next player to his right the
honor of going last and I'm gonna go
down to the end and start with one
player who has put up so many numbers
it's ridiculous he's won four US
Championships several events including
just recently dominating winning very
nicely in Paris
I'll give you will give you that he'd
had a great comeback after being down
phenomenal bliss player absolutely
fantastic rapid player and looking to
win back in his hometown he told me
today when I interviewed him he said I
don't like the way it went down the last
time I was here the u.s. shamsher didn't
go great for him so look for him to have
some revenge on his mind please welcome
a grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura
now in a tradition a country that has
amazing tradition of chess one wouldn't
expect it to be easy to be the number
one player of all time from Russia so
I'm sure he's smiling nothing he tough
who are you putting me up against
there's so many names but he has
certainly acquitted himself quite well
so much so he's one of the world's rapid
he's won several tournaments Norway
chess a couple of times but more
recently played against Magnus Carlsen
for the world champions title and gave
him all that Magnus could handle when
losing only in the tiebreak so a
fabulous player indeed and we like to
welcome again from Russia Sergey
Karjakin
[Applause]
and I didn't give the greatest moniker
to Hikaru because I think a lot of
players recognize the US has a pretty
darn good player who would take that
argument very difficult and Wesley I
think you're gonna have that same
struggle as well because there's one guy
named Bobby Fischer who we all recognize
is gonna be pretty tough to surpass so
humbly so he remains humbling you
wouldn't argue for that just yet but
he's on his way he's already won the
grand chest tour and he's the current
leader of this year's tour so please
give a big hand to grab master Wesley
sorry
[Applause]
without question by far the greatest
player this country has ever produced
and he's in line with the greatest in
all of chess he's won five World
Championship titles count them five
that's a lot if you got it you know you
got to start using a second hand to
start to talk about anything bigger he's
also won so many tournaments it's just
useless me trying to miss them all he is
indeed one of the great legends of the
game and continues to show why he is a
superstar and someone much beloved from
India grandmaster Vishwanath on ion this
gentleman is certainly one of the
gentlemen Joker's in chess he makes us
all laugh and smile and eat and he
relishes the role as a matter of fact it
seems smiling now happily that just
being described as such but he's also
got great competition in his country as
one Tiger Petrosyan was quite strong and
he recognizes as such nevertheless he is
one of the greatest players we have in
the world today he's been as high as
number two in the world and he is last
year's winner of this event so he will
be defending his title looking to have a
lot of fun while doing so as well
please welcome grandmaster Levon Aronian
[Applause]
and finally somewhat of a host I would
say of this event as he returns to st.
Louis he lives all of two blocks from
here so it's not far for him to walk to
get to work he has certainly had great
success here winning u.s. championship
he won the Sinquefield Cup by a score
that will be very difficult to match in
the history of time not just at the
Ziegfeld Cup in any tournament one of
the greatest performances by any player
in history and now he gets a chance to
try to make history that's to follow up
one Bobby Fischer is to become his
nation's next world champion we're all
rooting for you welcome a grandmaster
Fabiano part 1 so I can say really
without hyperbole we've got the word
greatest tagged on these players for a
very good reason so to have this kind of
talent in st. Louis it's absolutely
phenomenal we really appreciate having
you here I will have a few questions for
the players and we also open it up to
the audience if you have any questions I
know my client has this question ready
always there well start at the end and
someone who has seen this chess club
almost from the very beginning will
start in 2008 he played his first chess
championship u.s. championship in 2009
and he's been here ever since so he's
being able to watch the changes in chess
here in the United States and its affect
around the world so I'm gonna open it up
to the veteran of u.s. chess here hikaru
tell me what what does it mean for you
to see what has happened in the last 10
years here in chess in the United States
yeah well first of all I think it's
great what has happened here I know when
I came here in 2009 the whole landscape
was so much different I think we were
looking for someone who could sponsor
the u.s. championship and provide some
stability because have been rotating
between various locations the funding
was questionable and so starting with
the US Championship and pretty much
consequently every event since
it's just kept getting better and better
there more events now they're more
talented players who are being produced
in the US and who are playing here think
of Sam Shanklin obviously who's improved
a lot in the last couple of years but
also some of the juniors like jeffrey
zhang and a wonder liang it's just it's
great to see the talent that's being
produced now and i know when i was
growing up i had to travel a lot to
europe and just for these kids to have
the opportunities to compete here in the
u.s not have travel so far away it's
just fantastic and i mean at the other
day it's really all thanks to rex and
Jeanie so they've just done a phenomenal
job and something that i think you know
long after we're all gone it'll still
it'll still be in the history books and
it will all look back and thank the pro
they've done well I'm gonna jump to this
in the near you've had a chance to watch
this a from afar and now up close as
you've been getting invited to more and
more events right deservedly so tell us
what what it was like watching these
events happening and now getting this
amazing opportunity to blow well it's
great of course and I'm really happy to
be here again and thankful for the
opportunity that I've been given to play
against the best players in the world
and just to be here in San Luis is
always a pleasure it's not only I come
to play good chess but also the
atmosphere we see friends chess fans the
commentary rate and it's just a very
nice experience always to to be to be
here Sergei you know you have you live
in a place that has an amazing tradition
for chess Russia you were born in the
Ukraine the history speaks for itself
can you put a context to that and
compare it to what's happening here in
st. Louis
yes of course of course we have a very
big traditions in in Russia and also in
in Ukraine but but but it's very nice to
see that that here you're you know
you're getting stronger and stronger and
yes and and I think that he SAT is is a
clear favorite answer speaking in chess
chess chess team competitions or at
least one of the one of the biggest
favorites and and it will be very
interesting to to play in in the next in
a next tournament and I'm very happy to
be back in in st. Louis for the second
time thank you
[Applause]
you've played here many times you
haven't won a rapping and bliss event
yet though I want to throw that at you
so I'm just I'm just throwing it because
we have such a good time together
all right you're one of the leading
candidates to to qualify for London
what's it going to take for you to to do
it and give us your thoughts as well on
these kind of prestigious events I mean
first of all it's obviously a pleasure
to be here and to play the one chest too
but especially human it's my fifth time
already and I enjoy it just like so
first obviously I really need to be top
of my game because I mean
the guy said of me already of a good
margin and one guy looming down on me
it's it's quite pro so we need need to
up my game and to be to be ready for the
challenge by the way we want to extend
our congratulations to France World Cup
winners please everybody give him a hand
I let it learn Wesley you have won the
grand chest tour before and you're now
in first place that usually means that
people are chasing you what are your
thoughts now in your position in the
event and also being back here in st.
Louis yeah Berkeley's to be back in st.
Louis also to be leading a grand gesture
but I would like to point out you know
we're not halfway there yet because the
thing filled up obviously comes for more
points than the wrapping this term is
[Laughter]
always correct yeah well I'm very
pleased to be back you know sometimes I
do well in st. Louis sometimes I don't
if you can see in my history so this is
my I really look looking forward to some
great games here and hopefully everyone
will be in great form and especially me
great thank you for those thoughts
Chakri are told me something today that
it didn't even occur to me that this is
his first time here and I thought what
no you're kidding right this guy's one
of one been one of the best players on
the planet for quite some time he had an
opportunity a few years ago but there
was a conflict and he was able to play
and now he's here and it seems like it
couldn't be a tournament without such a
great player so welcome first of all to
the event tell us your feeling now that
you're here
this is you also mentioned to me an
interview in the interviews your first
time playing in the United States so
it's it's all new to you tell us what
that feels like now to finally be in
this place it's the first time will I
play in u.s. it's very strange but I
think it's a big problem because I
afraid the flights too long it's a 14 15
hour flight it is not easy for me okay
you know the US team didn't make that
excuse when we went to your country yeah
but I like it yeah it's flight which is
very good to play of course one of the
best player best tournaments in the
world it's a very nice very good
atmosphere it is I see people's playing
chess than chess club and speak about
chair night in my country is just very
popular fantastic popular popular some
football yes it is everyone speak about
chess but I think it is like my country
I mean about everyone's love chess and
it is very nice best tournament in the
world it is okay I mean I'm very happy
to play here and I will try improve my
chest and improve my English yes thank
you so much
[Applause]
we've got a long way to go to make
chances popular football here Americans
love their football that is American
football
it might rival soccer though I'm not
sure about that one
but also congratulations on your
fantastic result in bills I think Vichy
you have seen it seen a lot not as much
as Rex
but the 1886 era we forgive you for that
right but tell us about what you've seen
here you've been a welcome guest here in
this event and contextualize this event
being a five-time world champion and
having seen so many fantastic events and
well organized events
tell us about this event well it's
obviously a great pleasure to be here I
really love coming to st. Louis every
time I think because by now it you know
you know everyone quite closely it's my
fifth trip to play here and I've seen
even in the time that I've been here
that the Association but in st. Louis in
chess has grown there were a couple of
articles I read and these are not in
chess magazines a couple of articles I
read about places to visit and whenever
st. Louis came up in the list of things
to do in st. Louis
visiting the Chess Club Hall of Fame was
mentioned and also eating the kingside
diner so I thought it was really nice to
read that and realize the kind of place
that chess has come to occupy in st.
Louis as well so I mean that's entirely
due to the fantastic efforts of Jeanne
and Rex and everyone here at the club
and I can say that I've never seen a set
up like this anywhere else I really
sometimes say that these two streets
just like a center of chess and so it's
a pleasure to be here and
I'll try to do well in the tournament
thank you very much for those thoughts
[Applause]
I'm gonna go to you next
LaVon you've been playing in the sink
field Cup since the very beginning you
and Ricardo are the only two players in
the entire field in the entire world who
have played every single event your
feelings about playing in st. Louis and
your thoughts about everybody thinking
of you as sort of the Joker and he I
knew embraced that role so well you
should also remember that I was at the
match of steinitz against so good yes
yeah I think when first time I came here
I was you know I was a bit skeptical I
was saying oh you know wish we were
playing somewhere in a big city bigger
city you know New York or Los Angeles
and then I came here and and I saw that
we were like in the most beautiful part
you just walk around the park you see
the beautiful buildings an amazing
heritage that the city has and then I
started walking around the city and
saying that city has so much to offer I
mean from historic perspective and also
from current you know that the park is
incredible and yeah I can say that I
always love coming back here and I have
great memories of this place and so I'm
very excited I'll stay here this time
for a long time in regards to people
thinking that I'm the Joker well it's I
can only say that it's flattering that
people don't say something mean I mean
which they could so
when they keep it like that
nice so I I hope I will be a villain in
the tournament
[Applause]
and finally at least my questions
Fabiano you are you have been preparing
quite heavily for another event kind of
big event I would say but this event
comes first so along with
contextualizing what chess and st. Louis
has meant in these last 10 years and you
being able to come back to your country
of your birth and be a part of this
miracle and contribute to this miracle
what do you thoughts about playing these
two events as you prepare for the
greatest journey of your life
well my first time here was in 2014 and
I mean that tournament was extremely
memorable for me for many reasons but
also because it was my first time seeing
the San Luis chess club and seeing what
how Jes has grown and the United States
since I was a kid and since then it's
only grown even more thanks to the
efforts of Jeanne and Rex and everyone
at the Chess Club in the Hall of Fame
I mean chess has reached a stratospheric
level and I mean it's been great to to
watch it close up and as for the
tournaments I mean it's of course I'm
preparing heavily for the match and
that's always in the back of my mind but
right now I'm mainly focused on doing
well in these two events and my last few
events haven't gone really according to
plan so I'm hoping that I'll do better
here well here here I'm gonna open up
the floor now to a few questions I think
we have time for just a couple of
questions Mike I'm just gonna give it to
you because I know you always help Thank
You Maurice my client just calm and
actually I'm gonna change my question
picking up on what Fabi said so question
for eight of the nine players we could
answer briefly but if you could give
Fabi advice on how to beat Magnus
Carlsen I believe
I haven't done my research I believe all
of you have defeated Magnus at some
point so I don't think you're gonna get
my opening advice a general advice on
what you would do to defeat Magnus of
course Sergei almost did so I'm curious
when go down the line
all righty car ooh I'm gonna really keep
this brief very very brief just a couple
of words just just play the best moves
like like a computer just play like your
duty in million thankful Cup 2014 14 I
think I'm not being expert but anytime
my vision Magnus II was because I had
some interesting original sharp points
but that's what they said how you should
play against Fisher and didn't quite
work for Spassky sir
I'm sure I am sure that
Fabiana will find a better way I think
just obviously to try to win in in top
form at that point and just believe in
yourself if you play like same pickup 14
you can't even afford to get a few
drinks before so games okay if you will
play like 10.0 vinter nowadays
everybody's looking for past glory pixie
dust anyone else with any questions okay
great we appreciate that and we have
special award I believe we already
thanked some of the commentators but
I'll do it again now first of all my
partners in crime jenna fischer hottie
always wonderful always hosting the show
beautifully top form and grandmaster
yeah so Sarah won the golden voice of
chess
[Applause]
and we have the English online show I
believe it's Alejandra this time you
speak English no he's he's been doing
the spanish-language commentary and of
course is his bilingual miss it's quite
strong so he will pick up very easily as
all along with also one of our co
commentators who subs when I'm away
gallivanting in some strange country
he's always doing such a great job here
so we would like to thank Alejandro and
Christian Carrillo for what they're
gonna do a live short kingside diner I
believe all right I give them a hand
please
and we have Russian commentary and man
the rating level on this one is really
high very impressive first of all we
have grabbed master mirrors the chenko
who will be giving commentary along with
one player who could actually just like
move over here and come right here
grandmaster Peter Svidler so please give
them a hand
[Applause]
and we have a special award and this one
he's already gotten a lot of accolades
this year but he will get yet another
one and to do the honors again my
partner in crime Jennifer Shaw
thank you so much Maurice well this year
at us chess is three Spring Nationals
classic championships in Columbus Ohio
in Atlanta Georgia and in Nashville
Tennessee thousands of young chess
players wanted to wish good luck and
give some advice to our world
championship challenger Viviano Kara
Rana and Rebecca this is just a small
sample of their work so these chess
players ranged from age five to eighteen
and they signed these good luck cards to
Fabiano on his road to London I'm gonna
point out a few highlights a few of my
highlights from these I hope you win so
you can be world champ make Norway cry
get a dirty mate
Magnus doesn't know how to play verse
dot dot dot sorry that kid apparently
need a little more space and finally my
favorite especially from this plastics
hand win win win but mostly have fun
[Applause]
and we also have another award for you
this one I think was a pretty easy pick
this year's us chess grandmaster of the
year also goes to of course our world
championship Challenger
Thank You Fabiano and of course all of
us at u.s. chess and the st. Louis chess
campus and especially all the young
people are rooting for you
Thank You Jennifer and now it's time for
it all these players are actually
waiting for like who
so we're gonna get Tony rich exec the
director to call those that names out
okay and I'm gonna ask our chief arbiter
he's the director of national events for
US Chess Federation he's an
international arbiter handles most of
the major events in the United States
Boyd Reed if he would come join me up
here so we can let the players know who
they're playing okay so just so
everybody's aware the format for the st.
Louis rapid and blitz is essentially
true tournaments in one event the rapid
portion the players will play a
round-robin which means everyone will
face everyone else one time the Blitz
portion is a double round-robin so that
means everybody will face each other
twice once with white once with black so
in order to determine the order that the
players will face each other and with
which color to begin we have to draw
lots so we're gonna draw two sets of
numbers the first number that will draw
will be from the front boxes here the
larger boxes those have beautiful ties
in them that were graciously given to us
by Margaux petit II I think is how you
say it I hope I got that right beautiful
fashion pieces I think you all will
really enjoy them and we have
corresponding pocket squares to go with
them as well just inside the box and
tied the lid there's a pairing number
one through ten so we'll begin and ask
the players to come up one by one we'll
draw from the larger box for rapid and
then we'll draw from the smaller box for
blitz first up Alex Krisha so if Bobby
on the car you want if you would join me
first to draw your parent numbers
okay so fabi's gonna pick about 20 bucks
not that one
okay and Fabia's pairing number six in
the blitz portion Fabiano his drawn
pairing number ten laughing kills time
perfect
next up also from the united states
grandmaster a car nakamura the car has a
pairing number eight in the rapid
portion that your nice tie there too
nope leo next one's gonna be in one of
these boxes yeah that's the one number
two so the car was Perry never to
joining us next from Armenia Grand
Master Levon Aronian
and for the rapid LaVon has chosen just
inside the box lid here all right
so LaVon has chosen pairing number 10
and for the Blitz portion pairing number
6 thank you joining us next from France
grandmaster Maxine Bashir lagron and for
the rapid portion Maxime has drawn
pairing number 9 and for blitz parry
number 8 joining us next from azerbaijan
Grandmaster Shack rearm amiodarone for
rapid Shak his chosen pairing number 7
hold on one more and for blitz Shak
picks parry number 7 consistent joining
us next from Russia Grandmaster Sergei
Acharya
number one for the rabbit it's a good
number and number nine yep
number nine for blitz thank you joining
us next from India Grandmaster Vishy
Anand and for rapid vichy is chosen
pairing number three and for blitz also
number three so for our mathematicians
what are the odds that a player chooses
to from 20 and gets the same number
twice how many - yeah - and his next
grandmaster Wesley so for rapid Wesley
has chosen inside the light there parry
number four and four plates very number
one Thank You Wesley and last but not
least grandmaster from cuba linear
Dominguez now reminder that Alex cruise
ships not here so he'll end up with
what's left Grandmaster Dominguez chose
perry number two for rapid and perry
number five for blitz and then finally
grandmaster chris shook will end up with
perry number five for rapid and perry
number four for blitz so for the rapid
portion our round one pair is coming
right up
we have I'll name the players starting
white and then black Grandmaster
karyakin versus Aronian Domingues versus
about Sheila Grove anon versus Nakamura
so versus men and our oath and Grisham
versus car you wanna this is the part
that the players really care about so
I'm sure I'm gonna keep the short and
sweet and pass it off to Ruiz and we'll
wrap things up thank you all very much
thank you Tony well that's it we down to
the real meat of everything here we have
the players ready I'm sure their
thoughts are already going quickly what
am I gonna play against this guy how am
I gonna crush him tomorrow we'll let
them do that and we're gonna close today
don't forget tomorrow all the excitement
starts they'll be the live commentary
online you can check out Jenn yeas and
myself if you want to come and be here
kingside diner would be a ton of fun
with Alejandro and Christian of course
the Russian language commentary for
those who speak that marvelous language
you can get the two great grandmasters
as well mischenko and a peters fiddler
it's gonna be a ton of fun rapid chess
you know that's my favorite stuff
wrap it in blitz we're gonna have a good
time it all starts tomorrow
one o'clock Central Time of course we'll
be on the air ten minutes early at 12:50
to bring you all the action and let the
games begin
thank you everyone and have a wonderful
night
[Applause]
[Music]